what's up Wolfgang so I hope that
everybody has made it to the theaters by
now and has seen Avengers infinity war
if you haven't seen it yet seriously you
need to get to the theaters and see it
you're missing out on a lot of
awesomeness so since it's been out for a
few weeks now many people have already
begun to start talking about Avengers 4
and what will happen after Avengers 4
obviously with Avengers 4 everybody
who's been talking about time-travel
recently since it seems to have been
confirmed and everybody's been talking
about the characters that weren't in
infinity war such as hot guy or Ronin s
will be coming in and ant-man and the
wasp and then of course all the new
characters that will be coming in but I
think the big question is with Avengers
for and the fate of the MCU after
Avengers 4 is still who is going to die
in Avengers 4 pretty much all of the
original Avengers contracts are up after
Avengers 4 and many have not renewed
them such as Chris Evans and Robert
Downey jr. it's still unknown whether
these characters will actually die or
whether or not they'll just kind of
retire and pass the mantle on to
somebody else but a few days ago
Chris Hemsworth on Instagram released a
video that sort of hinted that he would
continue to play for after vendors for
and Thor is actually believed to be one
of those characters but we also know
that Chris Hemsworth has stated that he
has spoken with director Tycho @et
about Thor 4 and with his recent post on
social media it seems like he is hinting
that he would still like to play Thor
after Avengers 4 in the video he talks
about Avengers infinity war coming out
in China and how was the second biggest
opening of all time and the biggest
superhero opening of all time and then
he then goes on to think the fans and he
says thank you so much everyone who
continues to support these characters
and the Marvel Universe we're going to
keep trying to crank them out for you if
you let us now this may not be referring
to him coming back and playing Thor but
we do know that after Thor Ragnarok
Chris Hemsworth was revitalized really
he said
is more excited to play Thor than ever
which makes a lot of sense because thor
ragnarok was widely and hugely
successful and it was just an amazing
movie it was great it really was the
best Marvel movie in a while and it was
certainly the best Thor movie and it was
a great shift away from the first two
and not to mention Thor was amazing in
Avengers infinity war really his
character was awesome the story
everything was Stormbreaker and rocket
and teen grew it was made it was the
best part of the movie where he comes
down into Wakanda so yeah of course he's
excited to continue to play the
character especially when he's loved so
much and Thor has been widely successful
in the last two films Thor Ragnarok and
Avengers infinity war and not to mention
that Scarlett Johansson's contract was
up but it's been confirmed that there
will be a Black Widow movie in which she
will still continue to play Black Widow
so with Chris Hemsworth having openly
stated that he has talked with director
Taika Waititi about Thor 4 it seems like
this post may just confirm that he is
still going to remain Thor after
Avengers 4 but I think it's going to be
kept under wraps for a pretty long time
at least until a vendor's 4 comes out
because if they come out and blatantly
state yes there's going to be more Thor
movies then it's gonna be clear that ok
in Avengers 4 Thor is not gonna die
everyone hope that he doesn't I hope
that they make many more Thor movies
with Chris Hemsworth Beene Thor I've
made it known that Thor is my favorite
superhero and I know a lot of you tours
the same to you he's your favorite
superhero and I think that even if he's
not your favorite superhero you at least
like him a little bit but let me know
your thoughts in the comments below do
you think that Chris Hemsworth is going
to continue to play Thor or do you think
that he's done after Avengers 4 let me
know in the comments below and of course
we are still doing our speaker giveaway
we have about one week left it ends May
30th so don't forget to subscribe to my
channel subscribe to the stupendous wave
leave a like and drop a comment below
with your favorite superhero Thor no
excuse me thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]